this is what monoculture looks like the
crop in this case is sizal used for
making rope that's far removed from the
rich biodiversity Madagascar is famous
for as could be
but in this sterile sea lies a surviving
remnant of a huge Forest the sidel
fields replaced
the berenti reserve
and here you get an idea of what was
lost when the trees were cut down
ring-tailed lemurs wander the Forest
Trails
while the rest of the group sit to
nibble flowers in the trees
but the star of the show is a little
more elusive
then the safaka appears as only it knows
how
this though is a dance of survival Peru
safaka is critically endangered like
many Lemur species its numbers are
falling
I hook up with guide Olivia Gilbert
who's been walking these Trails for 30
years
and he tells me intense drought in the
South brought on by climate change is
making a bad situation much much worse
we've seen the number of the baby born
it's about only
a 30 or 40 percent of which is the usual
we have
so since five years quite unusual
happening in here is the number of the
baby born
from drought to deforestation the
pressures on Madagascar's biodiversity
are intense
on the west coast lies a spectacular
stand of bar above trees seven of the
world's eight species of power verbs
grow only in Madagascar
it is just extraordinary isn't it just
kind of sums up Madagascar's incredible
biodiversity and some of these trees
that more than 500 years old but of
course they're under threat
once these trees grew amongst the forest
but the forest has gone and the
endangered Giants are all that remain
bark exploitation for a house
construction
rope construction and the transformation
of the habitat into cultivation and also
they sell their fruits and their
regeneration natural is not enough to
replace population
of course what's going on here is not
unique to Madagascar in any way at all
it's happening simply everywhere in fact
of the 8 million species on Earth
currently one-third are endangered
because of human activities driving
Extinction levels from between one
thousand to ten thousand times natural
levels including 25 percent of mammals
14 of birds 33 percent of reef corals
and 40 of amphibians
a World's Rich biodiversity is a source
of constant Wonder but also critical to
the health of our planet a mosaic of
life that must be preserved
Nick Clark Al Jazeera Madagascar